Beamen oder hummer bikes und und solche geräte aus science fiction büchern das sind super
inspirationsquellen für forschungsteams weltweit doch inwieweit halten filme wie star wars dem realitätscheck
Stand ein britischer physikstudent hat sich jetzt mit dem klassiker aus dem science fiction genre
Beschäftigt mit den star wars filmen wie viel energie ein lichtschwert unter realen physikalischen bedingungen benötigen würde und wie viel energie
Für die zerstörung eines planeten mit einem todesstern nötig ist jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Konkret geht es um eine szene aus einem der ersten star wars filme also episode 1 die dunkle bedrohung der jedi meister qigong
Benutzt ein grünes licht schwert um ein loch in eine tür
Aus metall zu schneiden exakt elf sekunden dauert das ganze
Der britische student lockt willcox der university of leicester hat sich jetzt die frage gestellt wie
Realistisch diese szene tatsächlich ist die konkrete frage wie viel energie wäre dafür nötig sein ergebnis
7 megawatt das ist vergleichbar mit der energieleistung von 70 autos die vollgas fahren oder
Eines der größten windräder der welt in etwa ob sie dazu legt luke willcox diese hohe leistung aus einer
So kleinen quelle macht das licht schrieb zu einem effizienten gerät um durch dichte
materialien zu schneiden und druiden zu bekämpfen tja und hier seine berechnung für euch zum nachvollziehen
Die länge des lichts schwertes schätzt er auf 91 zentimeter dessen durchmesser auf 4 cm
Die metalltür in der filmszene mit seiner vermutung nach
titan deswegen verwendet der in seinen berechnungen dessen spezifische dichte aber lob willcox hat sich damit noch nicht zufrieden gegeben
seine zweite frage galt den unterschiedlichen farben der star wars lichtschwert
inwieweit unterscheiden sich diese in ihrer leistung seiner annahme die verschiedenen farben des lichts
Also ihre verschiedenen wellenlänge hängen mit einem unterschied ihres
energiehaushaltes zusammen sprich mit der energie der lichtteilchen also der photon die leistung des grünen lichts
schwertes hatte lok willcox ja mit knapp 7 megawatt berechnet demnach würde die leistung des roten licht schwertes bei etwa fünfeinhalb
megawatt liegen eine violette waffe dagegen hätte bereits 9,3 4 megawatt bei der annahme dass ein lichtschwert
ausschließlich photonen erzeugt wäre die violette waffe
Also die energiereichste doch wer von euch die star wars filme verfolgt
Sieht es eventuell sowie loboué cox
Demnach scheinen die lichtschwerter in manchen szenen eher plasma zu erzeugen ja google cox ist übrigens nicht der einzige
physiker der sich mit science fiction film beschäftigt und dazu durchaus seriöse berechnung einstellt schon vor einigen jahren gab es eine art
faktencheck eines forschungsteams
Um david baltzer stone ebenfalls von der universität leicester sie hatten sich gefragt ob es tatsächlich möglich sein mehrere planeten
Gleichzeitig zu zerstören ebenso wie in star wars das erwachen der macht ihr ergebnis ein
todesstern mit einem mega leser wäre dazu wohl tatsächlich in der lage
Damals hatten sie ausgerechnet welche energiemengen nötig wären um die planeten zu pulverisieren für die app erde beispielsweise
Hatten sie ein ergebnis von 2 mal 10 hoch 32 joule berechnet
also eine zwei mit 32 0 das sind doch glaube ich fantastilliarden
Ne quatsch also wer weiß eine zahl mit so viel nudeln also wie die genannt wird schreibt es in die kommentare
Und das ganz so vereinfacher. Hatten sie bei ihren berechnungen übrigens angenommen dass die dichte der erde
im inneren konstant sei
Das ist allerdings nicht ganz der fall wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert ihr geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken star wars
todesstern leser gebaut ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann